you created the tech type setting system
and released it as open source
just on that little aspect
why did you release it as open source
what is your vision for open source
no okay well that the word open source
didn't exist at that time but we but i i
didn't want proprietary rights over it
because i saw how
proprietary rights were holding things
back in the late 50s people at ibm
developed the language called fortran
they could have
kept it proprietary they could have said
only ibm can use this language everybody
else has to but but they didn't
they said anybody who can write who can
translate fortran
into the
into the language of their machines
is allowed to
make fortran compilers too
on the other hand in the typography
industry i had seen
a lot of languages that were developed
for
composing pages and each manufacturer
had his own language for composing pages
and that was holding everything back
because people
were tied to a particular manufacturer
and and then a new equipment is invented
a year later but printing printing
machines they have to
expect to amortize the cost over 20 30
years
so you didn't want that for tech
i didn't need the income
okay i already
i i already had
uh
like a good job
and
you know
my books were
uh
people were buying enough books that i
that that it would bring me
plenty of supplemental income for
everything my kids needed for education
whatever
so there was no reason for me to try to
maximize income any further
income is sort of a threshold function
if you don't have
if you don't have enough you're starving
but if if you get over the threshold
then
you start thinking about philanthropy or
else or you're trying to take it with
you but uh
but anyway there's a i had i my income
was over the thresholds so
so i i didn't need
to keep it and so i specifically could
see the advantage of of
making it open for everybody
do you think uh most software should be
open
so i think that uh
people should charge for non-trivial
software but not for trivial software
yeah you give an example of i think
adobe photoshop versus on linux
as photoshop has value
which so
it's definitely worth paying
paying for all the stuff i mean
and i mean
well they keep adding
adding stuff that just
that my wife and i don't
care about but
somebody obviously does but i mean but
they have
built in a
fantastic uh
undo feature for example in photoshop
where you
you you can go through a
sequence of a thousand complicated steps
on graphics and it can
take you back anywhere in that sequence
yeah
with really beautiful algorithms i mean
yeah it's it's
oh that's interesting i didn't think
about what algorithm it must be some
kind of efficient representation really
yeah i know i mean there's a lot of
really subtle
nobel prize class like
creation of intellectual property in in
in there
um
and uh
and with patents uh you get a limited
time to
uh i mean eventually the idea of patents
is that you publish
so that it's not secret it's not a trade
secret
that said
you you've said that i currently use
ubuntu linux on a standalone laptop
it has no internet connection
i occasionally carry flash memory drives
between the machine and the max that i
use for network surfing and graphics
but i trust my family jewels only to
linux
why do you love linux
the version of linux that i use is
stable i
actually i i i'm gonna have to upgrade
one of these days but
to a newer version of ubuntu yeah i'll
stick with ubuntu but
but uh right now i'm running
something that doesn't support a lot of
the new
software it the last day will be i don't
remember the
number
like 14. anyway it's it's quite
and i'm going to get a new computer um
i'm getting new um solid-state memory
instead of
a hard disk
you